[Musique]
il fait chaud on boit de l'eau au
mexique on se rafraîchit aussi avec de
l'eau les egos frais ska ou eau fraîche
sont parfaites pour se désaltérer
si vous allez au mexique là il faut vous
tenir prêt de marché vous allez avoir
toute l'offre de tout ce que vous voulez
les marchands des doors down et ska une
soit entre 8 et 10 options avec le héros
des gros tonneau plein de couleurs vaste
pays aux ressources variées au mexique
tout est bon pour parfumer sont nos
céréales fleurs tubercules ça pousse ça
sert bien à des classiques
c'est là au chat à lauderhill akamai cas
d'un chien demis cuse et les tamarins
que c'est un fruit de rue rinaldi alors
chat ainsi plus de sud rail cassé
vraiment partout tamarindo 6 et partout
dans cette petite taqueria de montréal
aussi l'amertume est ce nous apporte un
peu son mexique natal
chaque jour elle prépare les trois aguas
fresca ce typique de son pays au chat à
séoul au mexique et c'est d'une loi va
séduire
on les joue t on pouvait signer
manganella doublé de l'eau et beaucoup
de glace et souk
il faut reposer doré cours de la nuit
parce que en bout kebede de l'eau entre
al rit et on commence avec le mélange
eau
moins classique mais tout aussi des
adhérentes et pas du tout plu quand
roberto nous concocte une eau de cactus
lenovo de lait symbole du drapeau
mexicain
c'est un cactus qu'on consomme comme un
légume on a 17 ans lever les épines et
avec ça on peut faire une eau avec la
limite des tomatillos et du sucre et en
corse et des boissons qui ont plein des
propriétés antioxydantes stimulant pur
que leur physique chez les gars parmi
les classiques il y à aussi l'audi
m'excuse et de tamarin deux ingrédients
qu'on trouve facilement dans les
épiceries latino et la voix et camarès
et une flore et faune la flore et
américain ont décollé comme ça et si
selebi secousse
et ça c'est vraiment facile de les faire
il est allé familles qui préfèrent les
laisser reposer toute la nuit
tamaryn de cette eau fruits on les
trouvait ici à montréal dans une pâte et
c'est beau et on est un peu de sucre et
de la glace et c'est tout on utilise
même le cacao pour se rafraîchir
enfin demandé région il y en a qu il
mélange avec du riz en a qui le menace
avec du
malisse requis les plus connus s'était
crashé à oaxaca un sachet avec du maïs
un maillot europe i speak du mexique
le mât et sert aussi à préparer des agua
ce fait ce casse comme le psol roberto
de cuisine sa version inspirée du
chiapas
ils ont tous la cannelle alors une fois
qu on mélange tout ça ça nous donne une
pâte comme ça qu'il faut des liés à la
main dans l'eau pour aller chercher
cette justice comme ça ça c'est la basse
et tout ce qu'on a à faire c'est le
passeur malaxeur et ajouter plus d'eau
pour les rendre très liquides petites
choses de vanille et on finit avec le
chiffre une fois que la boisson est
prêtre là ils font l'amour
en fait les marchands des sages qu'il
fasse en attendaient leurs clients sont
toujours en train alors gars qui
commence et un autre merveille du
mexique c'est un tubercule qui ressemble
à une patate mais qui a une consistance
des pommes et on peut faire aussi une
rafraîchissante avec le concombre
limites et sucre avec toutes ces idées
boire de l'eau n'aura jamais été aussi
satisfaisant